on a personal level I believe President
Trump has tweeted about you unfavorably
54 times what is it like to you're
you're a citizen of the United States
now and you and and you don't have a big
position in Washington or anything
you're a guy and the present you wake up
almost every day and the president is
saying something about you or has said
something about you what is that like
it's like a breakup that he can't get
over it's I'm out there living my best
life and I wake up and there's some
tweet in the morning about it and it's
actually I've become numb to it and then
I stop myself because you can't become
numb to the president knighted States
announcing that a private citizen should
be in jail you can't become numb to the
president I say just making stuff up
doesn't have an effect on I mean I would
become a little paranoid if it were
happening to me and the president states
was tweeting angry stuff about me at
four o'clock in the morning I'd be
weirded out and I think it might affect
my family has it affected your your kids
your family your no I think they have
the same reaction the same number II
action to it which is there he goes
again but then we pull ourselves up
short and say first of all it doesn't
freak me out because there's nothing to
it there's no facts behind his
accusations but again I try to remind
myself this is not okay yeah I forget
your politics it is not okay for the
president United States to announce that
private citizen should be in jail I
don't care whether you're Republican or
Democrat and so I think my kids maybe
even more than I are able to push it to
the side and go on live in their lives
right
you